le débat sur la place du privé dans la
production de l'électricité au Québec
est-il relancé en tout cas le Premier
ministre le GO et le ministre Fitz Gabin
ont tous deux laissé entendre qu'ils
étaient ouverts à plus de privés dans
les secteurs énergétiques du Québec le
privé serait même plus efficient selon
le ministre et puis un nouveau PDG a été
confirmé cet après-midi à la tête
d'Hydro-Québec Michael Sebia un homme
qui a un certain parcours dans le
secteur privé lui aussi alors pourquoi
ce choix quel mandat a-t-il j'en discute
avec Norman Mousseau il est directeur
scientifique de l'Institut l'énergie
Trottier monsieur Mousseau bonsoir
bonsoir et Pierre Olivier Pineau qui est
titulaire de la chair de gestion du
secteur de l'énergie à HEC Montréal pour
ce soir monsieur Pinot bonsoir alors
avant de commencer la discussion je vous
invite à écouter quelques-uns de nos
élus sur la nomination de Monsieur Sebia
est-ce qu'il y a une volonté
de privatiser en partie Hydro-Québec oui
ou non le flou doit être dissipé
rapidement surtout que monsieur sébia a
quand même par le passé contribuer à la
privatisation de grandes entreprises
déjà il y a des projets qui sont faites
par le privé pensons à tous les projets
qui sont faits par borélix donc on a
rien contre le privé
c'est une bonne affaire l'éolien c'est
le PV ça va bien moi je suis jeune
voilà je pense qui lance bien le débat
alors je vais commencer avec vous
monsieur Mousseau il est vrai que le
privé occupe déjà une certaine place
dans la production d'électricité au
Québec n'est-ce pas
oui en fait l'éolien depuis le début en
fait depuis monsieur Charret en le
privatisé donc il soit complètement
privative ou depuis quelques années là
donc ce soit il faut que ça soit des
consortiums qui incluent privés et
communautaire mais évidemment il y a
beaucoup de petits barrages qui sont
privés c'est ça des petits barrages qui
fabriquent de l'hydroélectricité donc
donc cette part du privé actuelle
monsieur Pinault c'est pas une
représentent combien de pourcentages de
la production d'Hydro-Québec en ce
moment ça doit être autour de 15%,
peut-être il faut regarder les chiffres
exactement mais comme l'a dit normand
Musso c'est c'est l'éolien il y a les
barrages petit barrage il y a aussi des
petites centrales de biomasse
et il y a au Québec aussi il faut pas
l'oublier des grands producteurs des
draw électricité privés mais qui sont
des autoconsommateurs Rio Tinto par
exemple qui produisent pour eux-mêmes
qui produisent pour eux-mêmes et il
produisent des quantités importantes
d'électricité et ils sont privées alors
quand on dit quand on redoute une comme
Gabriel la douce voix de Québec une
certaine privatisation d'Hydro-Québec on
va quand même parvenir est-ce que
c'était avant la nationalisation de
l'électricité avant rené-l'évêque
monsieur Mousseau en fait l'éolien c'est
comme ça qu'on le fait depuis le début
on le privatisé ce qui fait qu'on a
coûté plus cher en fait le l'éolien est
cher au Québec par rapport à d'autres
endroits en Amérique du Nord par des
choix à la fois du modèle c'est-à-dire
des modèles avec les communautés qui
sont impliquées qui sont du
développement régional même chose les
centrales hydroélectriques au fil de
l'eau les petites centrales sont des
centrales qui sont essentiellement qui
coûte plus cher que les
approvisionnements qu'on pourrait
trouver avec des appels d'offres le plus
larges
expliquez comme c'est plus cher vous
dire que l'électricité qui est fabriquée
dans ces petits barrages par exemple
reviennent plus cher aux consommateurs
paye la moyenne si on veut mais c'est
central hydraulique au fil de l'eau on
les paye 900 kWh qui est nettement
au-dessus même des coûts de l'éolien par
exemple donc ce sont essentiellement des
projets qui subventionne le privé ou
encore qui servent à du développement
communautaire c'est-à-dire que une
municipalité va va
posséder une centrale hydraulique et va
retirer des fonds donc on utilise ça
c'est des petits des petites quantités
d'énergie mais en gros ce sont les
consommateurs d'électricité qui
subventionnent ces projets-là donc le
coût de production est plus cher parce
qu'on subventionne mais en même temps il
y a des retombées sur la communauté etc
si on peut intéresser parce qu'ils sont
pas alignés avec la demande normalement
la grande puissance est au printemps à
l'automne une puissance diminuée à l'été
une puissance dim de l'hiver donc ça pas
vraiment d'intérêt dans un contexte où
le grand problème au Québec c'est la
gestion de la puissance hivernale bon
que fait
ce gamin contre le privé qu'est-ce que
on peut envisager de donner davantage au
secteur privé dans la production
d'hydroélectricité au Québec monsieur
pignon personnellement moi j'ai pas
d'écrit grande crainte parce que
on sait que si vraiment on voulait
privatiser Hydro-Québec ou des parties
ça susciterait un énorme ressentiment
dans la population je suis une fierté
quelqu'un dans une grande fierté et à
juste titre parce qu’hydro-québec rend
d'énormes services et à globalement je
crois bien fait historiquement monsieur
le GO et monsieur fitgibond ne sont pas
des spécialistes du secteur de l'énergie
ils ont jamais vraiment annoncé leur
plan dans ces dernières années donc ils
sont un petit peu en train d'écrire au
fil des jours leur programme énergétique
ils sont proches du privé ils ont fait
des carrières dans le secteur privé donc
c'est sûr qu'ils vont dire qu'ils ont
rien contre le privé et c'est sûr aussi
qu'ils au Québec est énorme c'est un
monopole énorme très très gros et donc
c'est sûr que c'est probablement une
bonne chose de pouvoir laisser la place
à d'autres joueurs au Québec il y a
d'énormes défis en elle-même et alors
laisser certains développements à
d'autres développeurs ça pourrait
justement enlever de la pression sur
Hydro-Québec et quant à moi ce serait
pas forcément une mauvaise chose
attendez alors enlever de la pression
sur Hydro-Québec parce qu'on sait que la
demande va aller en augmentant les
besoins vont aller en augmentant et donc
Hydro-Québec en l'état maintenant ne
serait pas en mesure de répondre à
toutes ces besoins là c'est pour ça
qu'il faut aller chercher l'aide du
privé il y a de la demande en croissance
si les projets se réalisent mais il faut
aussi faire de la réflexion de barrage
il faut aussi renforcer le réseau de
transport renforcer le réseau de
distribution il faut mettre à jour la
réglementation et la tarification et
communiquer à la clientèle ces
changements-là ce qui veut dire que si
on demandait Hydro-Québec dans plus
développer d'autres projets importants
je pense que ça serait ça irait au-delà
du mandat spécifique d'Hydro-Québec qui
est déjà emmène large et quand on
regarde d'autres secteurs comme
îlot ou la commercialisation de batterie
tel que evload et une belle technologie
développée par Hydro-Québec Hydro-Québec
n'a pas de de compétences particulières
dans la commercialisation de ces projets
là et alors toujours demander
Hydro-Québec de commercialiser des
projets très innovants mais ça s'est
révélé être des échecs par le passé
alors peut-être qu'on pourrait laisser
d'autres joueurs commercialisés des
belles découvertes québécoises d'accord
avec ça monsieur mousse
en fait le problème quand on parle des
barrages au fil de l'eau ou des
centrales de l'eau c'est pas innovant
c'est des trucs bien connus ou en gros
il y a zéro risque donc dans ce
contexte-là privatisé ces centrales là
je vois peu d'intérêt pour l'éolien on a
besoin de vrais appels d'offres qui vont
cibler le coût de l'énergie et pas le
développement économique et qu'on vit
encore de voir aujourd'hui un appel
d'offres qui a été donné en Gaspésie
petit appel d'offres qui en gros sert à
du développement communautaire mais qui
a peu d'intérêt parce que les lignes de
transport sont déjà saturés et donc ça
aidera pas le Québec il est grand temps
de faire des vrais appels d'offres
ouverts et je large et là on verra c'est
au Québec production peut soumissionner
de manière compétitive avec du privé
présentement on lit les mains en fait
Hydro-Québec production et on l'empêche
de faire une compétition claire avec le
privé dans le secteur éolien
expliquez-moi ça commence quand on lit
les mains d'Hydro-Québec parce qu'en
fait on demande que ce soit des des
condensions privées communautaires donc
dans ce contexte là disons au Québec
production est mise de côté et ça sert
surtout encore une fois à faire du
développement régional ce qui fait que
l'ensemble des consommateurs paye plus
cher leur électricité pour faire du
développement régional déjà dans notre
rapport de la commission il y a 10 ans
ce qu'on disait c'est développement
régional devrait être porté par le
gouvernement et les la production
d'électricité de manière plus chercher
la manière la moins chère d'avancer mais
ça mais sur cet aspect que souvent
monsieur Pineau sur l'entretien sur le
développement nouveau marché plus pointu
pour lesquelles le gros Québec n'a pas
d'expertise est-ce que il faut laisser
place au privé est-ce que même on doit
le faire
il eau par exemple on devrait offrir le
même offre tarifaire qu'on offre à Elo à
toute compagnie qui veut s'installer
là-dedans il y a de la marge de la place
pour le privé dans de nouvelles
productions mais aussi dans la gestion
de la demande entre autres ou là on a
des on pourrait avoir une diversité
d'offres qui est beaucoup plus large que
ce qui est au Québec lui offrir présent
donc vous êtes d'accord tous les deux je
vous le ventais avec d'accord avec la
prestation du ministre fait du Gabin qui
dit que le privé est plus efficient que
le public monsieur Pinot là-dessus il
faut faire attention mais dans certains
cas il peut l'être dans d'autres cas ça
ça porte après judice quand on parle de
production d'électricité
je pense que ce que disait normand Musso
c'était que ça coûtait plus cher les
appels d'offres mais c'est pas la cause
du privé et c'est parce que il y a
effectivement des clauses de
développement régional et on a utilisé
de considération considérations qui ont
été prises en compte que ce soit privé
ou public c'est des contraintes qu'on
aime voir avec une une gouvernance de
l'État en fait
on a mélangé le le développement
régional avec la politique énergétique
on a fait un mélange des rôles et c'est
on va commencer par ce monsieur Charret
et on se retrouve avec ça avec du bon et
du moins bon je pense que les
entreprises privées elles ont plus de
souplesse plus d'agilité souvent que
Hydro-Québec il y a des très gros
syndicats Hydro-Québec qui ont pas
forcément toujours l'agilité nécessaire
pour être sur le terrain et au bon
moment aux bons endroits donc il faut
donner ça dans l'alliance de l'Est par
exemple qui est une alliance de
municipalité de l'Est du Québec pour
développer des projets éoliens ils sont
sur le terrain ils connaissent les
acteurs il s'allient avec des
équipementsiers et des gens qui ont géré
des projets éoliens ça peut donner un
avantage important pour développer des
projets quand il y a des gens locaux qui
sont dans les projets directement alors
Monsieur d'accord avec ça que le privé
peut dans certaines circonstances être
plus efficient que le public et qu'on
doit rechercher ça
chacun avec Pierre-olivier Pinault mais
dans ce contexte il faut ouvrir il faut
faire des appels d'offres qui cibles
coût de l'énergie on a besoin de
construire beaucoup d'approvisionnements
laisse du Québec en Gaspésie entre
autres oui il y a des alliances mais
c'est peu intéressant ce qu'on a besoin
c'est de déplacer les parcs éoliens vers
la côte nord vers les endroits où il y a
des lignes de transport importantes et
là faisons des appels d'offres qui
cibles la production d'électricité
ouvrant ça largement si le privé est
plus compétitif que Hydro-Québec
production tant mieux on en profitera
sinon que ça soit Hydro-Québec
production qui gagne mais on doit pas
présupposer de la de l'efficience sur
l'efficacité parce que le privé doit
rajouter à chaque fois un 15 % en moins
de profit qui est pas absorbé qui qui
nous revient pas donc qui va évidemment
secteur privé alors et pour le
consommateur est-ce que ça changerait
quelque chose ultimement que la
production une partie de la production
d'électricité soit faite par le privé
versus le public monsieur Pinault c'est
ce qui se passe déjà et c'est sûr que
plus les coûts d'approvisionnement sont
bas mais plus les coûts Québec zumba et
ça ça permet en théorie sauf qu'avec
d'avoir des tarifs plus bas sauf
évidemment avec la loi 30-4 et qui index
le prix d'électricité à l'inflation des
bas coûts d'approvisionnement en fait
profiteront Hydro-Québec et profiteront
au québecois avec une marge de avec les
dividendes exactement monsieur d'accord
avec ça aussi l'enjeu c'est qu'on ne
sait pas et ouvrons correctement faisons
des appels d'offres correctes où tout le
monde peut soumissionner avec comme ça
l'objectif d'avoir la plus faible le
plus faible coût si le privé compétitif
tant mieux sinon c'est au Québec
production le fait on y sera tous
gagnants donc je comprends qu'il y a
effectivement une tasse à faire au privé
dans la production d'hydroélectricité
d'électricité pour Diderot
nécessairement mais d'électricité au
Québec mais qu'il faut bien cibler
circonscrire les demandes les appels
d'offres les soumission qu'on veut
confier au privé en fait on ne sait pas
en fait la question la réponse est qu'on
sait pas parce que les appels d'offres
ont été très biaisés vers privé dans
l'éolien dans d'autres secteurs c'est
Hydro-Québec qui remporte dans le
secteur des grands barrages donc on n'a
jamais fait une vraie compétition pour
voir qui dans ce contexte là et le plus
efficace ou qui est capable de livrer au
meilleur couple intéressant monsieur
Hydro-Québec n'a jamais été conçu et
développé pour développer de l'éolien ça
peut se changer mais il y a toute une
liste un historique d'hydroélectricité
alors ça c'est pas des compétences qui
s'acquièrent comme ça du jour au
lendemain alors
le terrain dans le privé exactement mais
ce pinot monsieur Mousseau merci
beaucoup d'avoir été des nôtres à 24
heures ce soir merci beaucoup au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI